when jai folded that was the end that
was the that was the end of my
trajectory because
now i'm moving on to rca i did a deal
with rca because i didn't get dropped
it's just the label folded so
p the people did get dropped but i had
got another deal me and justin
timberlake on the same label so he got
moved to rca or epic and i got moved to
rca did a new deal but it's people who
didn't believe in me and understand yeah
the same people who we nr's the people
who brought you on the team they're no
longer there they're no longer there and
when you're like that in a re in a
building it's like you're in no man's
land it's no man's land so that's what
happened and that's the reason why i
kind of just
fell apart it happens a lot right
especially it doesn't even happen when
the label folds it happens when someone
gets fired yep
then you get somebody who doesn't the
president comes in they didn't sign you
they don't believe in you they just
following the numbers the analytics so
that's kind of what happened to me in
that space and you know stuff like that
has happened to a lot of artists for
sure and they and a lot of them haven't
recovered